a new poll finds First Lady Melania
Trump has a 57 percent approval rating
that's up 10 points since January mrs.
Trump formally unveiled her B best
campaign yesterday promising to work on
critical issues facing children Julianna
Goldman is at the White House where the
first lady's announcement came with some
controversy Julianna good morning good
morning
well sixteen months into her husband's
drama-filled presidency mrs. Trump is
trying to carve out a legacy of her own
focusing on children's well-being and
issues like cyber bullying bullying even
if some of that runs counter to her
husband's own behavior I believe we
should strive to provide kids with the
tools they need to cultivate their
social and emotional health with her
husband seated in the front row
First Lady Melania Trump unveiled her
platform to tackle childhood well-being
including opioid abuse and negative
behavior on social media it is our
responsibility as adults to educate and
remind them that when they're using
their voices but their were bullied or
online they must choose their words
wisely and speak with respect and
compassion just hours before the event
the president used Twitter to single out
two FBI agents by name he called the
Muller investigation a phony witch-hunt
an accused former Secretary of State
John Kerry of illegal activity I do
believe the children should be both seen
and heard the first lady offered few
details for her initiative but her staff
says it will draw on her experiences
visiting children's hospitals and
schools the launch was not without
controversy
the first lady's office appears to have
copied an Obama era FTC pamphlet
advising parents on screen time for
children and the slogan be best was the
target of late-night comedians must be
missing right there's got to be a word
it was either gonna be be best or do
goodest and they went with
she's a very intelligent woman who
speaks multiple languages fluently but
for everyone on her team who signed off
on be best be better this is Trump's
profile has risen in the past several
months she attended Barbara Bush's
funeral alongside for past presidents
and planned the recent state dinner for
the French president now aides say mrs.
Trump actually came up with that'd be
best slogan herself and as for the
Federal Trade Commission pamphlet mrs.
Trump's office says that the FTC
actually approached them and suggested
they use it and they were happy to do so
Gayle all right thank you very much
Giuliana